THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS.
BRIAN DEAN WRIGHT IS A
DEMOCRAT AND FORMER C.I.A.
OFFICER AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
I WONDER WHY IT'S SO HARD TO
COME TO A CONSENSUS THAT
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE.
NO MORE FAKE SOLUTIONS.
THE WALL, THE LENGTH OF THE
MEXICAN BORDER, I DON'T KNOW.
I KNOW NOTHING WE TRIED HAS
BEEN SERIOUS.
IT'S A JOKE.
JOKE THAT BOTH PARTIES ARE IN
ON.
WHY CAN'T WE DECIDE TO TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY?
>> FUNDAMENTALLY EACH SIDE HAS
REASONS NOT TO TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY.
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS THE
DEMOCRATS ARE PROPOSING $1.
BILLION JUST LIKE LAST YEAR
AND THE YEARS PRIOR.
MY PARTY SAYS LET'S DO THE
BUSINESS AS USUAL.
EVEN THOUGH IT IS GETTING US
3,000 PEOPLE ACROSS THE BORDER
EVERY DAY.
THAT IS CRAZY.
EVERYBODY WATCHING THE PROGRAM
AND REASONABLE PEOPLE WILL SAY
WHY ARE WE DOUBLING DOWN ON
STUPID?
BROKEN?
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
>> YEAH.
SO DO YOU FIND IT INTERESTING
THAT THERE REALLY IS A
BIPARTISAN CONSENSUS IN
WASHINGTON THAT WE ARE NOT
ALLOWED MORALLY TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT PEOPLE STREAMING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
THAT SOMEHOW IT'S WRONG AND
AGAINST WHAT JESUS WOULD DO TO
PROTECT OUR OWN COUNTRY.
WHERE DOES THE IMPULSE COME
FROM?
>> WELL, I THINK IT IS
SOMETHING I HAVE MY HEART THAT
I CAN LOVE JESUS AND LOVE THE
LAW.
AND LOVE THE BORDER.
I DON'T THINK THOSE TWO THINGS
ARE DISCONNECT.
THEY SURE SHOULDN'T BE.
SO WHY ARE PEOPLE USING THOSE
TALKING POINTS?
IS THIS ABOUT INFLAMING
PASSIONS SO WE DON'T FOCUS ON
FACTS, RIGHT?
BECAUSE IF WE TALK ABOUT
AMERICA NAZI, GERMANY AND THE
TRUMP IS HITLER, WE DON'T
FOCUS ON THE FUNDAMENTALS.
WHICH IS WE HAVE PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER.
MOST DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH OR
HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION.
THEY WILL BE A NET DRAIN ON
THE ECONOMY.
THAT IS A TOUGH SERIES OF
FACTS FOR ANYBODY TO DEAL
WITH.
AND TO KNOCKAGE BOND HONEST
ABOUT -- ACKNOWLEDGE AND BE
HONEST ABOUT.
THAT IS TRUE FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT LET'S BE
CLEAR HERE.
IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS WE HAVE
GONE FROM BEING NORMAL ABOUT
THE BORDER SOLUTIONS TO BEING
ABSOLUTELY CRAZY.
WE HAVE PEOPLE IN THE PARTY
WHO OPENLY ADVOCATE FOR OPEN
BORDERS.
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY IT'S
HARD FOR ME TO LOOK IN THE
MIRROR AND EMBRACE MY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY KNOWING FULL
WELL THAT MOST OF, OR AT LEAST
THE PROGRESSIVE BASE WE DON'T
WANT SOLUTIONS.
WE JUST WANT CONTINUED CHAOS.